geneviève de fontenay en colère oui
comme tous les jours depuis 20 ans une
fois encore c'est après une mise qu'elle
en a cette fois ci c'est nathalie
marquay qui a lancé les hostilités dans
tpm paix en expliquant les différents
qu'elle aurait eu avec la dame au
chapeau aussi à la téléphonie la france
dimanche pour dire à natal yele à la une
cervelle de pois chiches et surtout tout
ce qu'elle sait faire c'est se faire
culbuter dans les deux fois geneviève
qui n'aurait pas hésité à lui faire
quelques coups bas par le passé à la
commande une le faire part de mon
mariage
des accusations qui n'ont pas du tout
plu à geneviève de fontenay qui s'est
confié en exclusivité au micro des pmp
dit elle est malade l abus et des
drogués et quelque chose qui est pas
normal elle n'existe plus est sorti une
ma mémoire et l'ancienne directrice du
comité miss france ne s'arrête pas là l
insigne aurait même que nathalie marquay
n'aurait jamais mérité son écharpe
mais les gens préféraient la réunion
s'était pas elle qui voulait vraiment et
encore une assemblée très nul encore
plus fort pour elle nathalie n'aurait
même pas mérité l'attention d'un homme
comme jean pierre pernaut j'ai
l'impression qu'il a qu'il a épousée
surtout son écharpe c'est pas possible
que quel soit son niveau
et si on sait que geneviève déplore
encore ne plus faire partie du comité
miss france jean pierre foucault répond
je ne devais partie nous l'avons
regretté lorsqu'elle est partie elle a
fait beaucoup de choses quand vous
vendez un appartement vous n'allez pas
vous plaindre quelques années après que
le nouveau propriétaire refasse les
peintures alors geneviève de fontenay
est victime d'un acharnement
c'est ce qui vous intéresse tous on
attend bien sûr d'avoir alors on va
revoir ce qu'a dit nathalie marqué dans
cette excellente émission le vendredi
ouvert à tous animé par
l'excellentissime benjamin castaldi et
oui les yeux fermés mais le cerveau bien
nouveau il ya un truc terrible que j'ai
envie de dire à l'antenne à la quand
même vendu le faire part de mon mariage
non oui à france dimanche aux histoires
pour mon mariage je l'avais pas invitée
parce qu'on était en discorde et elle
m'avait supplié de l'inviter je dis non
je vous inviterai pas un point final et
j'avais invité son ami et j'ai su par
son ami qu'elle avait piqué le faire
part de mon mariage chez sa copine et
bizarrement le lendemain ça a été mieux
sur france dimanche en ont mais et c'est
fou sanat naft toi c'est tellement vrai
mais j'ai l'impression qu'elle rockeur
mois nous la grande rancoeur ça a été
surtout en 2005 quand elle m'a annoncé
quant à lady pour france dimanche que
elle a un pois chiche dans la tête et
qu'elle ferait et qu'elle s'est fait
culbuter dans les boîtes de faim dans le
monde
dans les bottes de foin pardon quoi
qu'est ce qu'elle a dit allah dit vous
avez un pois chiche dans la tête dans
les votes neuf fois ouaip ans dans la
ferme célébrités non quand il y avait
les histoires avec du cru non monsieur
horrible et donc naturellement elle dit
je mens mais ça veut dire que jean
pierre pernaut mans aussi patent je me
souviens quand il a appris ça on était
en train d en était en voiture on
descendait dans le sud et je lui lis ça
il s'est arrêté sur une aire de repos
il a appelé madame de fontenay je ne les
jamais vu en colère après il l'a
insultée ah ouais il a éclaté au sol
mais il était fou furieux et il a dit
occupez-vous de nos fesses non en fait
c'est bien occupez vous de vos fesses
ils ont été même coup de fil sur
apathique et elle veut tout elle veut
toujours existé et quelques tables ce
qu'elle dit il a accroché et c'est pour
ça que je me suis permise de dire
qu'elle me casser les couilles parce que
c'est ce que c'est elle qui avait
commencé à me dire de me fait culbuter
que ce n'est pas sympa dont avait depuis
si elle a dit ça c'est pas sympa mais
mais geneviève c'est vrai qu'elle s'est
attaquée de toutes parts alors réagi
notre jeu moi j'ai une tendresse pour
geneviève de fontenay vous allez voir la
rage il y en a c'est ce que on va voir
déjà le premier extrait pour geneviève
des attaques
regardez elle vous a répondu les
attaques de nathalie ont été très dures
ah oui et là des mots très forts pour le
dire
regardez ce qu'elle vous répond je ne
peux pas ne pas être ému c'est plus que
ça j'ai j'ai eu un choc
j'ai eu un choc j'ai dit mais c'est pas
possible que que j'entends des choses
comme ça qu'est ce qui lui prend enfin
j'ai jamais rien fait de mal j'ai jamais
jamais eu le moindre problème moindre
discussion dit elle est malade elle a bu
les drogués quelque chose qui est pas
normal ce pas normal
elle n'existe plus elle est sortie de ma
mémoire pour moi d'ailleurs à aider
situé alors pour vous pourrez connaître
plus miss oui pour elle je suis
peut-être pemis le testeur est
d'ailleurs la lune sans mot à dire là
dessus
et en plus ce qui est comique je suis
une seule miss france capa qui a pas eu
sa couronne parce qu'elle me lagarde et
elle m'a gardé ma couronne nord voilà
fait une galette des rois avec dans la
voix discuter comme ça elle fait mal au
coeur bien sûr parce que c'est une
personnage c est moi aussi elle m'a fait
souffrir quand elle commença à dire des
choses comme
heureusement que j'ai été élue miss
france parce que sinon j'aurais pas pu
être soignées pour mon cancer c'est du
n'importe quoi elle dit que j'ai vu que
j'ai fumé mais elle a fumé quoi aussi la
moquette
c'est pour ça qu'à un moment ça grâce à
un moment c'est c'est bon elle dit
qu'elle est venue plusieurs fois me voir
à l'hôpital elle n'eut qu'une seule fois
de le voir à l'hôpital
et vous savez à lasser de débrancher a
fait une chose terrible et elle me dit
que c'est pas vrai et docteur boris qui
est à villejuif il en est témoin elle
est rentrée parce que ça lui quand je
suis en chambre stérile
on doit enlever les chapeaux à
versailles elle n'a pas voulu enlever
son genre où elle est entrée dans la
chambre c'est à dire qu'à tout moment
c'est pour ça que je suis en travers à
tout moment vous savez très bien quand
on est en chambre stérile on à longchamp
pas le micro on peut crever être gratuit
donc c'est terrible regarde ce qu'elle a
dit te concernant encore nathalie que
nous a dit des trucs très fort il ya un
instant regarde serait j'ai l'impression
qu'il a qu'il a épousée surtout son
écharpe
parce qu'ils envoient entendu comme
l'autre jour c'est pas possible que quel
soit son niveau
parce que quand même c'est vrai qu'elle
arrive dans une maison magnifique et
d'argent et tout ça sans avenir est
assuré un bon réguler ces écharpes sorte
d'écharpé ne serait pas là non et emma
d'amendé à zinvié mon pauvre jean pierre
elle le prend pour un con là non non
mais franchement cesser ses dires il dit
n'importe quoi dit elle échappe
heureusement que jean pierre et il a une
autre image que moi que que les sharp
les chartes ça veut rien dire mais
indien bien sûr et mes jeux elle va très
très loin elle sait plus quoi dire quand
elle sait pas m'attaquez mois à la taxe
il vit quand ces passifs vi et ses fêtes
josiane ces voix-là cette carte jacques
etc c'est triste c'est bien triste mais
c'est lui collaert une question c'est
pas diffamatoire de dire ça non mais tu
dame à toi je veux pas qu'on fasse de
mal à générer moi je suis alors que je
suis pour que tous les essais
oui oui c'est vrai c'est vrai que
nathalie mais nathalie on la connaît
apprécié mais franchement ça c'est pas
très grave un scan guillemois saha le
dit natalia nous a expliqué voilà oui
guillaume je pense que la violence des
propos de geneviève elle est à la
hauteur de sa tristesse en ce qu'elle
est extrêmement triste d'être mise à
part surtout pour le centenaire de miss
france je pense que sylvie tellier
devrait mettre de côté un peu les curés
le cas lui avec elle en revanche avec
nathalie moi je suis vraiment scandalisé
par ce qu'elle dit surtout qu'elle
sous-entend que nathalie entre
guillemets rien sans miss france ce qui
n'est pas vrai déjà et nathalie elle a
toujours reconnu que c'est grâce à miss
france qu'elle a rencontré jean-pierre
ses graphismes ans qui est devenue
animatrice
donc je comprends pas cette querelle
avec nathalie et moi j'ai une question
j'ai l'impression que toutes les miss
s'embrouille avec geneviève de fontenay
pourquoi d'après toi mais c'est ça
surtout a embrouillé avec tout le monde
je ne sais pas parce qu'on est on rentre
pas dans son moon et donc ça va pas et
c'est vrai qu'avec sylvie tellier on en
a pas de 18 alors astuces et je dis bien
et loria et non mélodies saint amour
elles sont mouillés personnes à la fin
mais alors là jean pierre foucault a
donné son avis sur hyères sur le chef de
ciel et loisirs il restait très courtois
comme d'habitude hamon jean pierre mais
il prend quand même position pour sylvie
tellier dit j'ai l'impression qu'elle
saisit cette opportunité vers le 15
novembre 15 des séries toujours existé
pour qu'on puisse parler d'elle c'est
comme ça je devais partie nous l'avons
regretté lorsqu'elle est partie elle a
fait beaucoup de choses quand vous
vendez un appartement vous n'allez pas
vous plaindre
quelques années après le nouveau
propriétaire refasse les peintures est
clair net précis dit toi séjour perdre
énormément évolué l'élégance mais moi je
trouve que pardon mais c'est un naufrage
en fait la geneviève de fontenay va
arrêter de tendre un micro ondes les
marmots elle est sans doute mais pas
violent moi je la mets l'eau mais ça
mais vous l'aimez bien et on l aime
beaucoup parce qu'elle fait partie de
notre patrimoine va télévisuelle mais
malgré tout excuser moi il ya beaucoup
de rancoeur il ya beaucoup de tristesse
mais là de la méchanceté un peu
gratuites en étant d'une sorte de site
comme un peu grotesque qui fait beaucoup
de mal je trouve à la marque nice alors
moi je vais vous dire moi quoi le seul
truc l'usure bol c'est de d'être un peu
virulente sur nathalie parce que faire
l'amour que j'ai pour notre dose et
nathalie qu'est une femme et c'est vrai
qu'à traverser on va le dire nathalie
vous avez traversé des épreuves très
difficiles vous avez été gravement
malade on nous en avait parlé tout à
l'heure exactement puis vous savez quand
quand j'étais miss france en 87 avec
madame de fontenay c'est pas aussi
facile que maintenant parce que à
l'époque quand on était miss france
c'était ringard alors pour trouver du
boulot derrière et ben il fallait
s'accrocher
ah ouais c'est un travail est dix fois
plus et moi pendant une période dont
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir le titre de 6e
dauphine
de miss monde donc j'ai travaillé auprès
de man de fonder pour vous avez été quoi
vous avez été 6e dauphine à miss mans
nous non oui moi jean-pierre pernaut est
peu dire gp show là s'il évoluera mais
mais mais c'est vrai qu'après on est
dans la bande au madame de fontenay
n'était pas auprès de moi à ce moment-là
je suis reparti à zéro je partis dans
les i j'ai même travaillé sur des
marchés pour faire détatouer tatouage à
l'aîné et c'est grâce à pierre cosso qui
m'a fait de faire passer des castings
pour un saut de la haie c'est lui qui
m'a relancé dedans parce que sinon c'est
vrai que les miss france c'est pas comme
maintenant où elles sont sûres et
psychologiquement ou sylvie fait
attention à déclare-t-il à leur maître
l'artiste ilyes attention à elle et les
aides points pour être comédienne pour
être animatrice pour être bien sympa ce
perco sol un elle rigaud a jamais été
bosse il est beau tout le monde il a
tout il ya tout ça va toujours votre
pote ah oui ce que vous étiez là on
était on a eu un flirt pendant 1 une
galoche une galoche savoir c'est
deschamps corps à l'époque de la boum à
regarder ce qu'elle dit d'où elle dit
que vous n'auriez jamais dû être élue
miss france heures à venir contre mon
jeu s'appellera charb d'hannibal et
celle que les gens voulaient c'était la
miss réunion qui sera semer la pagaille
là bas en europe qui faisait le vote
écart qui comprennent époque la première
dauphine sans intérêt la 2e etc
mais les gens préféraient la réunion
c'est ce n'était pas elle qui voulait
vraiment et encore une afin d'être élu
c'est vrai qu'elle a raison qu'elle a
dit que j'ai de la chance d'avoir été
élu parce que même moi quand j'ai été
élue miss france j'ai été très choquée
et pour moi c'était ma première dauphine
qui réduit est élue miss france parce
qu'elle était très très jolie la chance
que j'avais c'est que c'était miss
réunion et que l'or à la réunion avec
décalage machin il appelait pas trop
mais ce qu'elle oublie de dire quand
même elle me disait heureusement que
c'était miss alsace parce que pour la
miss réunion sera été compliqué pour moi
parce que comme à l'époque on n'avait
pas d'appartement pour la miss france
aurait été compliqué de l'héberger
pendant un an france donc a été bien
contente de m'avoir à ce moment là et
puis avait quand même de 1000 voix de
différence par rapport à ma première
dauphine et je remercierai jamais bleus
cela ça vous blesse qu'elle dise oh oui
et non mais
en même temps elle fait mal au coeur je
comprends pas c'était vraiment votre
deuxième maman comme vous dites vraiment
vous étiez très très très proches ailier
on se parlait de tout on rigolait
énormément on a voyagé dans le monde
entier
elle m'a elma elle m'a appris plein de
choses à partir de quel moment s'est
passé l'été 2005 la ferme célébrités
2005 parce que on avait fait la ferme
célébrités donc sur tf1 c'est une
émission où des célébrités étaient dans
une ferme
c'est vous qui administre moi non non
c'est la ferme en afrique
bah vous êtes bon tous les deux parce
que je ne l'aimais raté le casting est
donc oui et là c'est vrai comme j'avais
fait du buzz enfin c'est pas moi qui ai
voulu faire du buzz par rapport à du cru
et où j'avais fait quand même 66
couverture puisque la mort violente
embarrassé il y avait il y avait des
cabines relation tous les deux avec
daniel ducruet alors que vous entendiez
très bien en fait c'est tout oui mais
moi je suis très tactile avec tout le
monde c'est encore pilippe réseau lippi
philippe risoli faisait partie de la
ferme pas bien sûr moi j'adore ces noms
comme l'audience est lui qui faisait
cuire les bananas et j'étais très très
proche de philippe risoli et pourra vous
le dire ça a été complètement déments de
m'inventer une histoire comme ça et donc
comme ça fait sur 66 couverture on ne
parlait que de moi et comme c'est au
mois de juin mais mme de fontenay était
un peu à l'écart on parlait pas des
allées des régions elle était jalouse
qu'on parle de vous autant oui parce que
non pas que de moi c'est que de tout le
monde a besoin d'exister tu déjà mais il
faut quoi aussi elle a besoin d'exister
à partir du 15 novembre à partir du 15
novembre à fait pleine polémique et on
le sait c'est chaque année comme ça
parce qu'elle me je pense qu'ils
arrivent et parce qu'elle croit qu'elle
est mise de côté et n'est pas mis de
côté est ce qu'on veut pas être
indulgent avec les gens doivent qu'à 86
ans arrivé en avion n'a voulu l'inviter
à miss france elle n'a pas voulu
même si vite ailier quand elle m'a
téléphoné en septembre nathalie ça te
ferait plaisir de faire partie du jury
de miss france j10 blaoui c'est un
honneur elle me dit mais je te préviens
tout de suite je vais appeler madame de
fontenay pour demander qu'elle soit
présidente du duc du jury et là je me
suis dit à bas coût de sylvie je pense
que si tu lui dis que je suis dans le
jury elle va pas vouloir venir dès lors
si tu veux sylvie à ce moment là c'est
plus important d'avoir madame de
fontenay
waouh jury et s'assit lutter il pourra
vous dire et j'ai dit moi s'il faut je
me retire pour madame de fontenay se
fasse partie du jury parce que c'est là
blême ces centenaires et c'est hyper
important mais c'était qui refuse tout
c'est elle qui refuse tout donc il ya la
paix sylvie tellier
[Musique]
ces 100 100 m dos et tout seul et c'est
deux et on aime on aime on a une
tendresse projet n'est pas ce que je
vais dire d'une tendresse pour les
arrière arrière arrière grand mère sont
là d'or ou l'infirmer monsieur mais il
faut qu'elle réussissait sortie de scène
j'aimerais tellement qu'elle soit sur
tf1 le 19 décembre
moi j'ai l'impression que depuis des
années le vrai problème c'est que le
produit miss france aujourd'hui c'est à
dire vraiment un truc hyper scénarisés
en termes de défilés etc ne ressemble
plus à ce qu'elle a fait pendant que les
chats élevé des années il entend dire ça
moi ce que je maîtrise et qu'elle a
l'âge de ma grand-mère et ça me fait du
chagrin d'amour aussi nathalie c'est à
dire on peut pas arriver à un moment à
dire des méchancetés pareil les je pense
qu'il ya de la tristesse d'un rockeur
séjourna on a envie on a envie de lui
faire des casses et salutaire dégage de
la fifa 12 en fait je l'imaginais chez
elle à 88 ans est donc effectivement je
cautionne ces propos qui sont à faire
puisqu'on était trop cinglant envers toi
nathalie mellal était chez elle elle
avait rien demandé à ses prix un tube tu
nous casses les couilles en pleine tête
donc du coup elle riposte à va pas tant
de lausanne mais si je disais si elles
sont toutes les caves et d'être beaucoup
de raisons avant mais c'était à 2005
donc du coup elle est l élan mais là
après moi j'ai eu souvent sylvie tellier
au téléphone où elle aussi elle n'est
pas bien été aussi en pleurs elle en
avait marre elle en a marqué fracassé
tout le temps sylvie tellier et un
moment moi j'en ai marre d'entendre
sylvie la pop de de devoir se battre et
où l'on savait que c'est la belle soeur
de jean pascal s'exciter un jour
ça peut faire une émission la lie à ma
position n'a jamais vu sa belle soeur il
a jamais vu c'est sûr elle m'a encore
confirmé qu'elle ne veut pas voir votre
temps de dire voilà oui d'aramon tu n'as
il faut dire quand même qu'elle est très
forte dans les scuds quand même malgré
ses 86 ans parce que là la fois l'avez
dit présenter les miss france faut pas
sortir de l'ena ensuite une année là en
2010 n'a pas voulu que ce soit marianne
james est partout et les dernières
voulait aussi que ce soit jean luc
reichmann donc évidemment je pense même
que jean pierre foucault ça n'a pas dû
lui faire plaisir
c'est tout le temps voilà on va voir on
va voir ce qu'on pensait téléspectateurs
tiens voilà miss france jeunes du monde
est elle victime d'argent nouveau
trottoir sans nom avoir de pause on est
plutôt du côté de nathalie